i got to tell the story sorry if i
thought yeah tell every story you want
we're here for it okay
yeah there was a girl there i used to
get 127 a week for unemployment
and i used to go to this bank it was
it was the bank that got remember the
bank that got shut out ridgewood savings
bank of popular yeah yeah that was the
bank that when the when the guys came
with the
uh automatic weapons uh on ventura
boulevard
i don't know oh are you guys too young
like the dog day
yeah no the guys came with the guns no
well anyway i would i would go there and
i'd give this woman a check
she was really pretty really knock out
and i would give her a check for 127
dollars a week on employment
and i kind of flirt with her a little
bit more
yeah the best chrissy just perked up
yeah yeah you know but she gave me
the heisman yeah you know who's this
older guy i'm 38 years old
making 27 a week i didn't get nowhere
yeah yeah yeah i'm not getting nowhere
without and every week i go by hey how
you doing you know
you have a good weekend yeah yeah it was
good yeah
yeah nothing yeah nothing so now
i'm home i'm i'm in my house with my my
friend my friend dayton kelly
oh my god i can't believe i'm going to
tell you these [ __ ] stories man
i mean it's okay if i tell you this is
what we're here for this morning
yeah i don't have any [ __ ] stories
with bobby yeah i mean yeah
i mean his [ __ ] yeah you you your
lowest moment of your life
you know you turning it to bronx till he
turned his lowest moment he he has a
trans character named marisa that he
does
that's it i got those stories that's it
my wife was mean to me last week
last night so i started calling her
hillary clinton that's my nickname
she's a nasty nasty woman so i'm sitting
there i'm sitting there and all of a
sudden uh
and then the doorbell rings i open up
the door now i'm living in a better
place
right i gotta i got a nice apartment
i'll learn
laurel canyon and uh i i get i'll send a
guy did you chase
josh bro i go yeah he gives me a [ __ ]
envelope like oh well thank you
now brock's tale's not happening yet
we're just we just made a deal months
ago
right nobody knows about bronx nobody
knows nothing about brock's that right
so my friend is sitting right on there
something like that in fact
that's the [ __ ] it was uh what do you
call that anonymous an ottoman yeah
nothing but i know it's an ottoman okay
and we're doing a [ __ ] scene we're
working on a scene for the theater
and i get this envelope and i go i'm
standing up
and i get the envelope and i'm looking
at it and i go
what what i go i go
to i don't forget i go dayton i said i
gotta check
will you march to send me a check for
fifty thousand dollars
you know fifty thousand dollars like and
he goes fifty thousand dollars
and i'm standing up now i was standing
up so he stands up right with me right
so i'm standing i can stand up right
yeah so i
understand i'm standing up like that so
he stands up
and we're like and he looks over my
shoulder and he goes like this
one two i see him counting the zeros and
he goes chaz
that's 500 000. and i go like this
you missed this you missed a zero i was
just so nervous that when i saw
i thought it was 50 it was 500 and we
went like this
we sat down he sat down over there
i sat down here just like we are right
now and
nobody said a word for three minutes at
least
not a word and all of a sudden
[ __ ] tears start rolling down my face
and i start [ __ ] weeping
i don't know i think it was like all the
built up chords it's a release it's the
emotional release all the hard work
all the grind yeah you can pay off your
gambling debt now yeah
yeah what are you doing yeah like
[ __ ] guys right were you writing in
your room
right i know you you were guys right so
i get the [ __ ] thing
and i said holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
me right so then i go back the next day
and who do i see
the girl there i got to give her the
check yeah right because i got to open
up an account right
she's there again i go hey you look
pretty today
yeah yeah yeah
i hand the check over that's nice
uh hold on one second and she goes
and started making empanadas for you
right and all of a sudden he comes out
the guy
they're like the manager with the suit
opens up mr palmer terry step in here
when you get him some coffee
[Laughter]
right all different yeah totally
different
good to see you every time she would see
me
how are you yeah oh my god it was like
i said no no no you know yeah no i'm not
giving in to this one no no
as much as she was beautiful nah yeah
not doing it she wouldn't have passed
the door test
she wouldn't have passed the door where
does the door test come from that's one
of the most famous things in movie
you know what people go with chad you
wrote the i said no i didn't write it
i'm gonna be honest with you
it was just something that we talked
about when we were kids that if a girl
opens the door for you
and i'm just the first one to put it in
a movie right and i made it famous but
you know it was something that we always
said if a girl doesn't open up the door
and if it's raining really you gotta
dump it right away that night you gotta
dump it
we really hope you enjoyed that episode
whatever it was about this is just a
stock thing that we're taping on to
every episode
so go make sure you rate review us
subscribe uh turn on your notifications
get jiggy with it and go to
patreon.comridgeboys where things get
really wild